it's great to be joined today by s
matthew liao who is the director of the
Center for Bioethics at New York
University also author of the right to
be loved and moral brain the
neuroscience of morality there's so much
to talk about here and I think maybe a
good place to start is when we talk
about neuroethics what are we talking
about so basically there are two
branches of neural ethics there's
something called the ethics of
neuroscience so this is sort of ethical
issues of arising out of novel new
neural scientific technologies so things
like their fmi which are sort of
functional magnetic resonance imaging
they're sort of different diagnostic
tools they're different drugs psycho
pharmaceutical drugs that one can take
and all those different new technologies
raised host those ethical issues so for
example they their implications for
things like addiction borderline states
of consciousness their issues about
erasing memories and so on let's talk a
little bit about to dig into one of
those issues the erasing memories idea
and this is an idea that the last
hundred years of science fiction have
opined a lot on that hypothetical
technology you have a great TED talk
actually available on YouTube which I
encourage people to check out which
deals a little bit would be this idea of
erasing presumably painful memories from
someone's past talk to us a little bit
about the concept and what the ethical
issues involved are sure so it turns out
that you know a lot of people right now
they experienced trauma so for example
soldiers coming back from war many
suffer post-traumatic stress disorder I
think about 23 veterans commit suicide
each day so it's quite a really serious
problem and right now there are new
neural scientific technologies that may
allow us to ameliorate some of these
effects so one drug is something
propranolol and this is something it's a
beta blocker so it's something that you
take when is very traumatic event
happens and what that does is that
memories have to be consolidated into
from short-term memory into long-term
memory so when you take that beta
blocker you can block the consolidation
process or at least dampen the
consolidation process I mean that way
the hope is that it would make the
post-traumatic stress less sort of
serious there are other technologies
there's something called deep brain
stimulation that people are using so
another theory about post romic post
traumatic stress disorder is that it
sort of involves hyper activity in the
amygdala so basically the laker lockets
that's the emotional center of the brain
and so deep brain stimulation is
something it's an electro that you you
place into your brain into a specific
part into your brain and then it's
connected into a battery pack and you
can turn the electricity up or down and
they'll then send the battery pack will
send electricity into the brain and
thereby disrupting signals in the brain
and so the idea there is that somehow
you can maybe disrupt some of the again
disrupt the post traumatic stress
disorder a more speculatively sort of
scientists have been uncovering
something that's really novel right now
is that they've they'd realize that each
time we recall something so every time
we remember something from the past the
memory needs to reconsolidate and what
that means is that it needs to put
itself back together so so and that
process of reconsolidation requires new
proteins something some people have
thought that it involves something
called PKM data and so the idea is that
if you somehow interrupt somehow use
something to stop the that protein from
forming itself you can very selectively
erase certain parts of the brain and it
would be kind of like the moving eternal
sunshine of the spotless mind right so
it's a lot at face value this all sounds
great right but but of course these
ideas are not without controversy what
are the the opponents to some of these
technologies arguing as the basis for
their opposition yeah so you know many
people are worried about just some
people might use this to some other
people so you can imagine a criminal who
commits a crime perpetrate to cry but
then gives the victim of drug kind of
like you know the date rape drugs and
then the victim doesn't remember that
would be really really bad and then
there are also issues about whether some
people worry about whether we have a
duty to remember maybe there's some some
you know maybe their duties to remember
traumatic events so these soldiers in
war or maybe some people think that
maybe they should try to remember the
atrocities of the war so that they can
tell the rest of the world so that we
don't repeat the past again and so there
are issues like that they also sort of
more subtle forms of self-harm so memory
is something that we use to they're
meant to represent what happened what in
fact happened so if we start tinkering
with what in fact happen we might start
to have a bunch of false memories and
that could be very troubling so as a
soldier you might take this pill and
then you might think that you didn't
really want to kill the enemy when in
fact you lusted after the killing and so
issues like that that those could be
really troubling I don't know why I
don't know if you've seen season 3 of
black mirror but there's an episode in
that which very very closely
approximates the the issues with
military that you're referencing right
now oh yeah I think I've seen that
episode ABM it's really great its exact
what I've been thinking about and
Matthew when we talk about the that you
mentioned fMRI I'd love to talk a little
bit about that and you there's a
controversy there are some in the
philosophy world who believe that
there's really not much value in using
neuroscience to determine what is of
moral significance or ethics to humans
and they look at some of the
experimentation that's being done with
fMRI under sort of ethical moral
decision-making situation as being kind
of a waste of time I'm guessing you
don't agree and I'd love to hear from
you why right so I think that I mean it
i think it's an empirical question but
also a normative one whether fMRI or
some technologies like neuroscientific
technologies will have ethical
implications let me sort of step back
and just roughly present the ideal
scenario yeah so the thought is
something like imagine that you know so
all of us when we make moral decisions
we use our brain and to do that you know
like some of us think that we do it we
think that were moral agent so we make
decisions in a very rational manner
right we think about the pros and cons
and we really deliberate about them and
then we come to a reasoned decision but
suppose that it turns out to be the case
suppose we put ourselves under fMRI or
some sort of brain scan scanning
technology and we we find out that every
time we could make a moral decision what
happens in the brain is really that
we're just kind of flipping a coin right
just to be dramatic yeah right in that
case it seems like you might start to
wonder whether our decisions are any
good assuming that flipping a coin is
not a reliable way of getting at k moral
truths and so that's sort of the ideal
scenario is that if it turns out that
when we make more decisions which is
kind of making up store
reads or confabulating or flipping coins
then that's a problem for the way we
make moral decisions well when I read
about the when I read some of the
statements from philosophers that say
there's no value here I'm sort of
reminded of the writings of Daniel
Kahneman for example dan Ariely who have
pointed out some of the consistency in
the lack of rationality that many that
humans exhibit when making many moral
and ethical decisions it seems to me
that while fMRI or seeing what's
happening in the brain might not be the
the answer it seems to me like it would
certainly be valuable to see what is
happening neurologically at the time yes
that's right well people like Daniel
Kahneman are actually fairly supportive
of Ephraim I think they are fairly
supportive of fMRI studies so the I
think that some of the the pioneers of
these fMRI studies is sort of applying
these studies to neural moral
decision-making in fact rely on Daniel
Kahneman to work on heuristics so for
example Joshua green green he basically
makes a claim that when we make the
ontological judgment so this is sort of
a debate between there's a sort of an
old debate between consequentialist on
the one hand and the ontology on the
other hand so the consequentialist say
that you know when we make moral
decisions we should do what you know
what will produce the grid the best
consequences right and that the
oncologists say that well no
consequences matter and but they're not
the only things that matter there you
know people have rights that people
they're sort of intentions matter and so
on and so that debates been going on for
a really long time and people haven't
been able philosophers haven't really
been able to settle it so they try to
use something like I mean if they view
something like the trolley problems so
the trolley problem is the case where
imagine that there's a trolley going
down the track and it's about this
five people and then you can divert you
there's a switch you can sort of divert
the trolley onto a side track will kill
one person so the question is should you
switch it onto the side track now most
people say well five verses one in that
case they say yes we should switch the
angeles-area approach that's well well
even the ontology even the non
utilitarians tend to say not not all of
them but about 70 some percent they've
done a survey they've done these surveys
so many people say yes it's okay to
switch it over the interesting thing is
so here's a variation it's called a sort
of imagine the trolleys going to towards
fight people again now this time there's
somebody who's really big on sort of an
overhead bridge and you can push the
person right off the bridge and then the
trolley will hit the person and and stop
thereby saving the five and
interestingly many people say that you
know you shouldn't do that because you
know sort of they just sort of have this
gut intuitive reaction that you
shouldn't do that and what's really
interesting about these two cases is
that there but they both involve saving
five people and killing one person right
and so if you're a utilitarian you
should think that you know it's the same
in both cases you should do it right as
you switch and you should push the
person but many the oncologists think
that no you should push the person and
so the question is why do they think
that and so Joshua green from Harvard
put subjects under fMRI and he found
that when subjects who think that you
shouldn't push the person you know off
the bridge when they are responding to
that particular dilemma the a big
amygdala is sort of firing sort of a lot
there's sort of activities in the
amygdala and amnicola again is sort of
this emotional region of the brain so
using the work of Daniel Kahneman
sort of says that well that's sort of
using a you know sort of evolutionarily
it makes sense for for human beings to
be averse to sort of up close contact up
close personal harm so you know in our
sort of during the caveman days right
people used to club each other and so so
naturally we evolved to be aversive to
physical harm right pushing people
hitting people and so on and that's what
we're reacting to so he sort of claims
that that's why we're reacting to when
we're pushing but now that we are you
know in this modern in in all modern day
that doesn't apply anymore so we're
using a bad heuristic and so so he
thinks that the fMRI in fact suggests
that we should be consequentialist
rather than T oncologist well let's go
down there and that that's exactly where
I want to resume our conversation
tomorrow we've been speaking with s
Matthew Liao who is the director of the
Center for Bioethics at New York
University the book is the right to be
loved and moral brains the neuroscience
of morality we'll continue our
conversation tomorrow on that note we're
continuing our conversation today with s
matthew liao who is the director of the
Center for Bioethics at New York
University author of the right to be
loved and moral brain the neuroscience
of morality when we left off yesterday
we had a bit of a conversation about the
consideration of consequences in the
morality of actions so let's maybe start
on that note today there are many people
who when when when faced with whether
it's the classic trolley problem or
other ethical decisions about whether
the means justify the ends there's often
a focus only on consequences others tend
to focus only on the morality of the
action and tend to say whatever the
consequences are if the action was moral
the consequences don't matter how can we
sort of open a conversation about the
different points of view on that yeah so
that's that's a sort of sets of
perennial debate is being ongoing the
way so yesterday we talked about sort of
the trolley problem
and one example I did was this sort of
there's a trolley going towards five
people right and you can switch it onto
the side track where it kills one person
right and many people think that it
would be okay to switch it onto the side
track to hit one person I mentioned
about 70 some percent now I think that
there are other things besides
consequences that matter and so here's a
variation of that example where I think
could show that it's not just it's you
know morality is not just based on
consequences so just take that case
again take that switch case again right
now imagine that the person on the high
track is your enemy right or it's this
individuals enemy right and so and
imagine the person who could do the
switching on to the side track doesn't
care about saving the five people right
instead this person just wants to kill
the person on the side track and so he
switches the trolley onto the side track
and sure enough it kills the person on
the side track so how should we think
about that case and if you're a
consequentialist you should think well
the person save five people you know
minimize life and that's that action
should be permissible right his
motivation the motivations in switching
over to someone who is their enemy
should not be considered because the
consequences are the same that's why
Adam it's good right because you say
five you know the consequences in this
case saving five people outweighs the
the badness of killing one person right
right but if you thought that
motivations matter then you should think
that what this person bit was murder
right this person killed the consulate
it's exactly the same case the only
difference is that the motivations
aren't different in this case so if you
have the intuition and I think I don't
know what you think but many people have
the intuition that it would be wrong
for an individual to switch to try to
kill that person on the side track for
that reason yeah I mean myself as I
think about it if I imagine scenario one
which is you see this train hurtling
towards five people you run over and
flip the switch and you move it away
from the five and it kills one person
you have no relationship to any of these
six people it feels I very different
than seeing the train hurtling towards
five people noticing that your enemy is
strapped to the side track and saying oh
this is a great opportunity to kill my
enemy running over and flipping the
switch the action is the same but
there's no doubt that it feels very
different to me yeah yeah and if that's
right so that would suggest that some
morality is tracking that intentions or
motivations could also matter in
addition to consequences what other
examples do we have that might give us
maybe a different gut feeling but still
apply to the same consideration is there
another example we could think of there
are more sort of controversial examples
where I mean some people talk about
Oregon here here's a sort of organ
transplant case yay so imagine that
somebody is going to the hospital /
fixie healthy person goes through the
hospital right and there are five people
in need of five different organ parts
say kidney lung liver as I try cetera
right and so now you can kill this
person and and take the healthy person
and take the healthy persons or organs
and put it into these five people
thereby saving the five people should
you do it I think you shouldn't but my
producer is nodding his head yes so I
think he likes this scenario no I'm
kidding know that it's right you're
choosing to end one person's life to
save five lives which from a
consequences perspective is no different
than the earlier examples but now you're
talking about something that's
completely different yes yes so what
what objective differences have been
sort of established as the reasons why
this feels different from for many
humans for most humans i would say good
yeah so once one explanation some people
have give have given it's something
called the doctrinal double effect and
this is the idea that intention sort of
sort of whether you're intending to use
somebody as a mean so whether you
foresee that some bad effects is
happening but you're not intending that
effect to happen so let me just explain
so take the trolley case again in the
initial switch case we just switch it on
to the side track the idea is that when
you switch it onto the side track and
the person gets killed you foresee that
the person gets killed but you don't
really intend that the person gets
killed now why is that and so a way to
think about it something called the
counterfactual test so imagine that this
person that individual wasn't on the
side track then you would have switched
it over right it would have been a
no-brainer sure you wouldn't be able to
save the five people by switching it
over to the high track but in the case
of say going back to what what we talked
about with respect to pushing a person
off the bridge right in that case you
need that person in order to save 25
people you're using that person as a
mere means right you're intending to use
that person in order to save the five
people and some people think that that's
that's a difference that this idea of
the doctrinal double effect so it again
imagine the counterfactual if the person
weren't there then they would be nothing
you could do to save the five people
right on the bridge in the in a bridge
what you know over the bridge where you
know there's nobody there right so in
the limited time that we have left I
wanted more time to talk about this but
unfortunately we don't have it the
ethics of reproductive technologies
which is an issue again that you've
studied and written about and spoken
about I'd love for you to give our
audience some introduction in
to some of the ethical questions around
new reproductive technologies sure so
with the ver bunch of new reproductive
technologies on the horizon so
especially something called crisper
which is this thing it's a gene editing
tool which you can it's basically great
like a search and replace function you
can just go in and very sort of find
very specific part in the genes and
delete or replace or at different genes
to it to that part of the gene the
genome and this enables people to
possibly do remove diseases so some maps
have been trying to use it for cancer
for HIV for Alzheimer for schizophrenia
as cetera et cetera but it also has the
potential of allowing us to create to
design human beings and that raises all
sorts of ethical issues it should you
know should we be doing this at all so
some people think that it would be very
bad it would be sort of we would be
playing God to be sort of interfering
with human nature like this other people
worry about the unintended consequences
because this would be involved germline
modification and those genes could be
passed on to future offsprings it would
be very hard to control and also and
then but other people say that well
maybe we have an obligation to do it we
should we have an obligation to produce
children with the best chance of having
the best life possible and yeah so sort
of there are different ethical issues
around that my own view is that I think
we should try to make sure that all
percents have enough of what i call you
know something i call the fundamental
capacities for being able to pursue
a good life and so these are sort of
various so what are these capacities you
know we need to be able to think to be
able to interact with other people to be
able to move about to be and so there
are sort of different core capacities
that we need and so I think that genetic
modification shouldn't tinker with our
fundamental capacities but if they're
sort of other things that we want things
like you know we want to be stronger be
more intelligent etc etc my own views
that that's not as controversial on its
own there could be other reasons for
being worried about these type of
modifications things like equality of
access like who gets these type of
enhancements etc etc but that's a
slightly different type of issue well
all issues that are going to be
increasingly discussed over the next
year's that's for sure we've been
speaking with with s Matthew Liao who is
the director of the Center for Bioethics
at New York University the book is the
right to be loved and moral brains the
neuroscience of morality it's been
really great speaking to you I really
appreciate it yeah it's really fun to
speaking with you as well thank you